now if that's so if that's so I need to
work out what the forces are in relation
to this diagram and then I can see
what's going on however you notice all
the way through the past in fact all of
the motion you have ever done in the
internet and extension one an extension
to has always regarded things as a point
or a particle do you remember that now
the reason why is because if you
consider something which is not a point
right something which actually takes up
space even just adding a single
dimension to our object which by the way
you only get a single dimension to
actually properly account for when I
give you a better model for this to
properly account for what's going on
okay just adding a single dimension
makes things a lot more complicated so
I'll explain what that's gonna look like
later on but for now what we need to do
is settle on a point to think of as
where is the cyclist okay so here is how
much space the Sacre sticks up they're
very thin okay I need to pick one point
on this line where I want to sort of
calculate all of the forces okay now
what do you think would be a reasonable
point I can think of two good candidates
for the point to consider as where all
the forces are any suggestions okay so
the first thing I heard was the middle
okay so maybe something like this okay
now that makes sense that makes sense if
you're thinking about gravity okay
because gravity is all that a center of
mass okay so it's a bit like saying oh
you know if I average you all that and a
mean or an average is a measure of
central tendencies well that makes sense
if you think about there that should be
around where all the stuff is happening
okay but it's not the only choice what
other choice could I make okay the
second equally valid choice is this guy
down here right now the reason why this
is useful is that gravity acts here
mainly but there's something else which
acts here what is it yeah the friction
and the normal force both of those okay
now that's really important to me
because frictions kind of became it's
actually making the turn happen right
and gravity is just kind of there okay
so as a result because I have to make a
choice I think actually in asking the
point
the tires contact the ground and that is
what I'm going to define as a point
where all of the forces are sort of
circulating around okay wonderful so
what I've got here is a we know this
gravity that's good
so this gravity remember I'm imagining
that the entire mass of the cyclist and
the bike is all in this single point
here okay so therefore I'm imagining it
passes you then I've also got the
reaction force the normal which of
course is perpendicular to the surface
that the ground so there goes the normal
foster as then I want more force to come
for friction right so the friction the
lateral force okay it's going in this
way okay this is the lateral force the
friction force and this is pretty much
it that's pretty much it
now remember over here the important
position of the angle was like the most
natural place to measure it was from the
ground from the ground you measure R
okay where do you think is the most
natural point to measure the angle of
the cyclists inclination from now you
can measure for the ground there's no
reason why everything look like we'll
just swap sides and cosines and that
kind of thing I think it's actually more
natural to measure from the vehicles
they all want to give me a suggestion
for why that's the case
yeah that's right a normal cyclist is
upright this this is the regular
position of a cyclist and this is
different like it's not like a psychosis
issue going on on the ground leg or how
far up showing your client it's how far
down should they equip does that make
sense okay I've got all my setup that I
need now I'm just going to resolve the
forces and work out what's going on okay
so let's do the vertical first
vertically what's happening to that
point it's stationary thank you you're
quite sick your scene is probably but
that's okay right so have a look what
forces do I have they're acting
vertically I just have it ng like so
I've got
take away energy that force of zero
gravity down normal up so N equals
lovely okay horizontally key tell me
what's going on okay all there is is
that lateral friction force right and
that's the only thing that's making the
turn actually happen right so the
uniform circular motion comes solely
from this guy right so what I'm going to
say is it is facing us into the term so
I'm going to say negative L heading
towards the center of a circle now it
should be now you can define this in
terms of Omega or in terms of V we're
talking about logic that's traveling
around and we know it's speed so I'm
gonna say so far so good
yes we'll get to the angle in a second
right the reason I haven't had to
account for the angle is because right I
have a look at this and have a look at
this vertically horizontally look come
are all these forces are facing right
how they give them up off at an angle
answer none of them they're all up down
or left right so no my solution we've
been required so far okay but if I add
everything together there is a force
that's off at an angle and it does
involve this thing on okay so if you
have a look here let's add in a couple
of extra lines you do like so you can
see currently I've got theta in this
triangle over here does that make sense
because L is heading in this way and
it's a rectangle that means I also have
L up here does that make sense like
they're just reports of sight
so what ratio is n which is actually an
elected sign what ratio is connecting
theta to these other signs that I know
about these other forces it's just going
to be 10 I have a look at tan theta is L
op opposite on adjacent so tan theta
equals
on in yeah so what happens when we put L
on m and V squared on o / mg M cancels
G's gonna hop onto the denominator hey
that looks kind of familiar right
this is exactly the same result we got
with the bad strats and this is why you
will find leading cyclist questions
in the textbook under the section for
bank acts because this simplified bottle
thinking about the cyclist is this point
and therefore where all the forces out
there it lands at exactly the same point
so that's where our does that make sense